game three final game of this three-game
series john means on the mound for the
orioles today the left-hander
facing the nationals as the orioles try
to win another series 2-1 nobody out as
druba cabrera 9-19 right handed
weight back waiting and he jacks one to
left and it's on the ground trey turner
coming around he'll score easily and
just like that maybe martinez revamped
lineup puts a run on the board soto to
third and cabrera to second the bases
are loaded big spot for carter kibum and
they're both been busy already with
right-hander jorge lopez now it's three
and two
he boom hits one hard to left and it is
caught by smith
tagging and scoring juan soto nets lead
to nothing
imagine the young man's got tons on his
mind right now
it's already a good inning looking for
the two out knock to make it a gradient
and how about that coming around third
cabrera as drooble pumping his way home
throw way offline
that's a second time in this series
dwight smith's row from left field went
closer to the mound than it did home
plate and it's three nothing
that's going to do it for john means 27
year old right-hander jorge lopez
bounced to the left side
police finally ends the inning but the
nats get three and on the mound pretty
good one man yeah they're gonna face the
best in baseball max scherzer here's
anthony santander
well hit way back
and that one is
fair ball out of here
anthony santander
takes scherzer out to the flight court
area with a sixth home of the year the
orioles are on the board
my goodness i believe that's a utah
street home run there you talk about get
out of here in a hurry here's how the uh
last inning ended brandon hyde or
somebody in the orioles dugout said hey
that's a strike there's the 3-1 pitch
we'll do that too meaning we'll start
arguing calls and get close calls and
then you saw the whole and heard more
importantly the stuff between davey pay
attention to the game and then juan got
rung up on a
pitch that looked like it was ball four
here's chance cisco he just filed one
off
scherzer trying to ping bring the curve
all around through the back door now
we're gonna have more going on here
oh that's it there they go yeah he's
gone yeah i think kevin long got thrown
out there so second and third one out
and now kurt suzuki can try to be a
cleanup hitter right here right now
huge at bat
oh boy that's a loud sound out to right
center chasing it down is mullins
turner scoring easily and soto read the
ball was going to be caught he gets to
third carter has an rbi today with a sac
fly in the first jammed base hit
dugout loves it two rbi day for carter
keep him and the opportunistic nets do
it again three runs on four hits in the
first two runs on three hits here in the
fifth orioles with a really good
opportunity here they'll have two
chances to get a base hit to score two
but you gotta score at least one in this
situation still some time left in this
ball game and sure is not far from
coming out of this one oh that's ripped
way back
is it fair is it foul it's a fair ball
and a three-run shot from pedro severino
and the orioles are right back in this
game at five to four
boom time
lean on one big fella or did he get all
of that one montander 11 game hit streak
now six homers on the year 21 driven in
oh that's well hit
santander has done it again and we are
tied
how about that
second home of the game for santander
and the orioles
have come all the way back down 5-1 to
tie this one up
one for two with an arbiana sac fly
breaking ball away
rolled over to ruiz and the ball gets
away
short arm throw soto scores
and max scherzer
again becomes the pitcher of record all
right what an unforced error by the
orioles
ruiz just kind of gooses it over there
and nunez really didn't have a chance he
pulled the throw too just never loved
infielders that grab the ball take it
out and then pat their glove with it and
then take it out again it throws off the
rhythm on your lower half a big second
out here in the ninth
alberto with a single and a strikeout
one for four career against daniel
hudson
got him on the slider low and away game
over series over and this was a hard
fought baltimore battle today yeah nice
win on a travel day going to atlanta
tonight and that scored six runs they
were
58 and eight when they scored six runs
last year so some people around town
questioned the lineup today it did a
nice job